[Music]
good news paris hilton is back on the
scene she reemerges in fact at the same
time as lena dunham two people who are
much closer in iq than they are in
physical appearance with these two
grabbing headlines again all we need is
amy schumer to come out out of hiding
and the three most annoying women of the
last 25 years will be sharing the
spotlight at the same time
the fourth horse of the apocalypse will
finally be upon us so we can get on with
armageddon already
but hilton is not focused on her past
she is very much a woman of the present
and of the future so she appeared on the
tonight show this week to promote
whatever the hell she's promoting and
also to have a conversation that our
ancestors would have found utterly
impenetrable and mystifying even most
people alive on earth today will
probably have that reaction
listen to hilton and fallon discuss nfts
i jumped in i know i heard i'm so happy
i taught you what they were you did you
taught me what's up and then i bought an
ape i got an ape too because i saw you
on the show with people and you said you
got a moonpay so i went and i copied you
and did the same thing you did mm-hmm
this is your this is your name
it's really cool
like the hat the shades
and what
how do you pick because because you can
pick your your your ape yes i was going
through a lot of them and i was like i
want something that like kind of reminds
me of me
but like
this one it's it does i think we made
like another version of it where he
takes the hat off and blonde hair comes
out
yeah because you could do whatever you
want mm-hmm animated version we're part
of the same people we're part of the
same community we're both apes i love it
uh here's my this is my yours
yours is so cool i love the red heart
sunglasses i love the captain hat it
reminded me of me a little bit because i
wear striped shirts
i've worn these heart sunglasses because
my daughters
just as a joke they have them and as a
joke i put them on so i've done this and
i love yacht rock and to being breezy so
i'm like yeah
that kind of and i like the blue mm-hmm
dude look at this they look like they
could be friends they're buddies
yeah i can't quite explain it but
something about that 77 second clip
sends me spiraling into despair
and paris hilton has always had that
effect on me honestly but this is
something even worse
as you can see in the clip they're
showing off their nfts which are digital
images of cartoon monkeys and hats
and they both spent hundreds of
thousands of dollars on them
not even for the card that fallon is
showing off but for the digital
representation of those cards the
audience of course is perplexed and
doesn't know how to react
should we applaud the two millionaires
who paid for a monkey picture that cost
more than my house should we laugh
let's do both that seems safest let's
laugh and applaud the obscene decadence
and emptiness of our culture
for those who are still perhaps confused
about nfts all you have to know is that
they are as stupid as they seem
they are what you thought they were to
paraphrase dennis green may he rest in
peace
your confusion probably stems from your
assumption that there must be more to
this fad there must be something you're
missing there's no way that it's as
idiotic as it appears to be i mean it
looks like people are spending thousands
of dollars buying digital pet rocks that
have absolutely no inherent worth use or
purpose and whose monetary value is
based entirely on a sort of collective
mania
that can't really be it you think
but no you were right the first time it
is that these are like beanie babies or
pez dispensers but worse because adults
are collecting them and also the things
don't even exist
the pez dispenser at least dispenses pez
what does the monkey picture do
you can sit and stare at it and reflect
on the meaninglessness of your life but
that's about the only function they
serve
nfts are artificial
their value is artificial now some nft
apologists will say that the same is
true of physical art i mean what's the
difference between owning a digital
representation of a cartoon monkey in a
hat
and owning say the mona lisa
well first of all you're a [ __ ]
second the mona lisa is a physical
painting a physical object created by
the hand of an all-time master and it
exists in the physical world where there
is just the one
it has 500 years of history it took
years to make it's not a digital
phantasm which is not only ugly and dumb
looking but which can be obtained by
millions of people all at once
all you need to do is take a screenshot
of the monkey and you own it as much as
paris hilton does i took a screenshot of
that
and now i have it too it's mine now
i'm the nft owner now paris hilton
now you may not have the original code
or whatever that's what the nft oh is
the original code and that's what makes
who cares
it's exactly the same thing
there's no inherent difference between
your screenshot and her original
this by the way is a problem that nft
merchants have run into a few months ago
the guy who made that youtube video 10
years ago called annoying orange which
features an orange talking and being
annoying
tried to sell the original video quote
unquote as an nft but then a bunch of
people on the internet simply stole it
because anything could be stolen on the
internet with ease
and the plan fell apart and so now he
just instead released it again he
re-released the youtube video on youtube
again
now you might say that physical money is
also artificial in the sense that it's
produced and its value is in many ways
subjective you're on perhaps more solid
ground with that comparison but the
problem is that nfts take all of the
worst aspects of artificial fiat
currency and amplify them
it seems to issue a challenge to
physical cash saying oh you think you're
inherently worthless and artificial well
check this out
nfts are the worst kind of fiat currency
you know we call it fiat currency
traditionally because the value of your
20 bill comes from the government's fiat
it's declaration
that the thing is worth exactly that
amount
now there are significant problems with
that system but it's not as bad as the
monkey cartoon which has value based on
paris hilton's fiat
rich stupid people have declared that it
has value and it will it will retain
that value as long as the rich stupid
people remain interested and as long as
enough non-rich stupid people continue
to care
not exactly the basis for a stable
monetary system yet this all makes sense
in a certain way
because we live in an artificial age
artificiality is our calling card it is
the hallmark of our culture and there is
nothing more artificial than an nft
well for now anyway as we've discussed
on this show before the next horizon is
horizon which is what facebook is
calling the metaverse
and that is the virtual reality world
where uh according to mark zuckerberg's
vision you can abandon your flesh and
blood existence entirely and immerse
yourself in cyberspace
this week a commercial for facebook's
metaverse went viral though the ad is
actually from a year or two ago
what you should know is is that the
actual metaverse as it currently exists
looks worse than it does in this old
advertisement
so this is the metaverse at its
theoretical best
and it's still a nightmare watch
beyond our world
there's another world
and it's right here
on my face
welcome this is horizon think of me as
your guide self-appointed spokes avatar
here to show you around you know horizon
is filled with possibilities he can play
stuff make stuff fly stuff wow really
love the stash stuart
what up stewart wait i want a mustache
horizon isn't about rules or limits or
pants
or people telling you not to fly an
airplane while drinking your fresh
ground fair trade french press morning
coffee through a curly straw isn't that
right debbie
so there it is i i love in even in the
ad uh how the women who are you know in
the metaverse
they're they're with their husbands at
home
and totally ignoring
their family so they can have this dumb
thing on their face
so if you want to block out your
immediate physical environment and
everybody in it so that you can inhabit
the floating severed husk of a nick jr
cartoon character and interact with
other disembodied beings in a sterile
and artificial environment constructed
by big tech oligarchs and designed to
give them direct access to your brain
then boy are you in luck
i just never realized that our dystopia
would look so much like paw patrol
what's the point of the metaverse
what are you supposed to do in it well
zuckerberg says that you can you can
have virtual meetings
so if you want to experience all of the
worst aspects of zoom conference calls
and in-person meetings with none of the
benefits of any of them then this is
your solution you can also shop in the
metaverse we've looked at walmart you
know walmart is now constructing stores
in virtual reality so you can flee from
the confines of your mortal frame and
experience the unfettered joy of retail
shopping
there's so many things you can do with
metaverse the hope is that eventually
you'll do everything in the meadows it
will be like the matrix but a lot less
cool
now you might think that this will never
take off you know it looks so bland and
dismal and pointless there's just no way
any significant number of people will
ever choose to involve themselves in it
and you might be right i hope you're
right but consider that our ancestors if
you had asked them
would have declared with confidence that
nobody in the future would ever choose
to sit around on their butts for 13
hours a day staring at images on screens
and yet here we all are
if you had shown them a cell phone and
told them that in the not too distant
future people would spend the majority
of their days simply staring at it
that they would even stare at it when
they're around other people that they
would ignore their children and their
spouses to stare at it that they would
ignore that the flesh and blood humans
in favor of the screen that they would
be so committed to staring at it that
they would kill themselves because they
can't stop staring at it when they drive
their cars
that people would literally be walking
into walls and off of cliffs because
they can't take their eyes off the damn
screen if you had told them all that
they would not have believed you
they would not have seen what could
possibly be so appealing about the
screen that it would compel us to
forsake our physical existence for it
most of us though we live this way still
can't explain what's so appealing about
it
i have a theory
and it's why i believe the metaverse
will very much become a thing and soon
it will become the thing the only thing
the reason is that the purpose of all of
this artificiality in modern life
is to numb us to the realities of human
existence
because out in the world in life
there is joy and fear and pain and
suffering and love and hate and death
and that's too much for the modern man
that last thing death you know is
especially too much for him as his
reaction to kovid clearly demonstrated
so he buries his head in his screen
it becomes like some kind of existential
anesthesia
this is why people flee into the
metaverse because
it allows them a final escape from any
semblance of authentic human existence
so soon we'll all be fake like paris
hilton
with her two hundred thousand dollar
monkey picture
another cheerful thought upon
and that is why nfts and the metaverse
and perisic
are all today canceled
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends